good morning boy what time is that it's
it's it's 8:00 a.m. what else would you
be doing that coming to the Javits
Center for the book Expo America author
breakfast you know it's a fine tradition
a rite of passage if you will
good morning my name is Lance finnstrom
and I run Book Expo America and I'm
really really proud to wake you all up
look at this I said he couldn't have
coffee unless he was kind to me and I
appreciate it Craig very much thank you
all for getting up early and joining us
today we're delighted to have an amazing
amazing line-up of authors and as always
we're incredibly thankful to all of our
publishers that have worked with us so
closely to bring this eclectic
interesting and delightful group of
authors this morning so please join me
in welcoming to this very lectern mr.
Craig Ferguson good morning everyone my
name is Craig I'm an alcoholic
the yeah and if you're up at this time
in the morning chances are you you are -
III I'd like to just first of all thank
you for having me here we're in in the
in the company of proper proper writers
who who've really got some I mean come
on some of these people here it Tracy's
when the pillow surprised yes because
his sensational bandage that is that is
the talk of Hollywood and and and and
I'm here and I I haven't III want to
talk to you a little bit about my own
book I actually don't
but HarperCollins wants me to talk to
you a little bit about my book but but
first of all I I'd like to i haven't
read everybody on the panel's book yeah
I much like everyone else in this
business I read the back of the book and
go home good and but I I'm about 150
pages in Jeanette's book and I have to
say it is terrific really it's a
sensational book and I was worried after
that it's really good and after the
glass castle I was thinking oh well you
know
so long and but no it's it's really
terrific and I have to say that the
Jeanette buck is better than mine it's
it's it's not only is it written better
which it is but it is it it doesn't have
me in it and that that improved the book
enormously for me I say though that it
looks maybe it's an oversight and I
haven't really read the entire book
there seems to be an absence of fart
jokes I don't know if the if the editor
has taken them out or not I I know that
that can happen
many of you know David Hershey my editor
at HarperCollins he will actually add
fart jokes to your book should you want
more fart jokes in your in your next
book you know Dave's your guy my my book
is is is a memoir about me apparently I
haven't read it yet but I'm sure it's
lovely no I I wrote it now the whole
thing when you write a memoir especially
after the whole thing people get very
upset because the James Frey thing
because you know as you of course
remember it was a million little pieces
of [ __ ] and and you know people get very
concerned I believe Oprah was horrified
the entire publishing community was
horrified I know I was horrified when we
found out the junkie had lied because if
we can't trust the junkies then I mean
really who can we try John Key this is
perfectly true to life he's lying you
talk to any junkie they will say you
know yeah you smoking crack like nope
it's Virginia slim it's my sister's I
anyway my cookies not the memoirs of a
junkie is the memoirs of an alcoholic so
it's a completely different thing
members of a junkie pack of lies memoirs
of an alcoholic made up some stuff
because I can't remember what actually
happened but but it's a face
it's a book about coming to America in
in in an emotional sense as well as
becoming a citizen I became a citizen in
2008 but it's also about becoming an
American in a very kind of old-school
way as opposed in the sense that it was
a philosophical decision it was an idea
which I subscribed to an a subscribe to
now it's certainly at the time I wrote
the book it was the end of the the
bush-cheney administration and the they
there there had seemed to me the
American patriotism had been hijacked
for some kind of mad parade and and I
wanted to have a look at that because it
seemed didn't sit right with me I've
always loved this country a great deal
but like everyone I love I'm not blind
to their faults and I love them because
of their faults as well as or in spite
of their faults or or maybe I don't know
it's in the book anyway that's why I
wrote the book and also because I was
talking earlier on Tracy was very very
kindly you know asked me what Glasgow
was like with the country with which the
country well there's no way I suppose a
country Glasgow is there is a town in
Scotland I'm from and it's a it's a town
which if you don't know it it's a little
bit like if you imagine the movie
Braveheart set in Detroit in the 1970s
it it's it's a it's a tough it's a tough
town and and I'm not so tough I I
imagine if you're the book Expo
breakfast you'll probably not that tough
yourself and so you I'm sure you can
empathize many of the people here I'm
sure were bullied mercilessly at school
but we've all got jobs now and [ __ ] them
haha
the the the the truth of the matter is I
I am I was talking to the rest of the
panel backstage and I the the thing that
we share
with the they share talent I share a
kind of pushy editor and a powerful
publishing house and a TV show but the
but what I think I think everybody it's
kind of awkward to talk about a book
you've written that I think because
because it's in the book uh what I had
to say is it's in the book and then if I
say again you think Miley's just seen
what's in the book yes but maybe I'm
prejudging your judgement and back you
can get ahead of yourself with that kind
of thing
I've had a lot coffee this morning it's
weird enough no no that's bare okay so
what we'll do is we'll have a I'm not
quite sure how this works I am a vulgar
lounge entertainer so basically what I
would probably do is just walk up and
down because of it and hope that would
be okay but I I think what we do is
we're gonna have a panel and and these
are my very esteemed dais buddies are
gonna talk about their their works and
and we'll and we'll find out about that
if I can think of a question I might I
might ask it you know to throw them off
and try and make myself look good that's
kind of what we do here and I think
that's the only thing else I would say
to you is at the end I've no very
important to say this the everybody kept
saying tell them at the end you're gonna
be the booth I don't know what the booth
is but I I'm gonna I'm gonna be there
you know I'll be at the booth don't you
dare try and talk to me and tell them at
the booth because apparently that's a
huge someone will tackle you and the I
can I just say before we go any further
as well what a delight it is to be in
such a kind of cafe environment you know
nothing says to me literacy like a giant
pharmacists convention where you know
it's like being in a cafe in Paris
really isn't it
just sitting here you know talking about
stuff with the light and anyway we'll
get on with some proper grown-up writers
and not some you know pushy twerp and I
I know who's starting that do I know him
Tracy are you starting no listen listen
to Tracy because he's won a pure
surprise he's very nice and very very
clever he's much smarter than you so
don't you go then oh I don't know listen
he's he's smarter than you they all of
these people are smarter than you and me
so don't go you know you hear me New
York Times alright did I just get booed
by the New York Times well it's happened
in print so why not and yeah all right
well so Tracy would you do is the owner
Tracy
good morning thanks a lot
after years of writing about people in
places close to my New England home
closer and closer after a while they
were just down the road I went to Haiti
for a story about American soldiers and
while in Haiti I ran into a young doctor
named Paul Farmer eventually I published
a book called mountains beyond mountains
which is about farmer and about about
about Paul Farmer and about the
exemplary organization that he helped to
found Partners in Health in the course
of my research I went with farmer to
Peru Paris Moscow Siberia Montreal
Chiapas New York and more times than I
can now remember to Haiti collectively
those trips were like a harrowing of
hell through places like Hades famished
deforested central plateau and Moscow
central prison and a peri-urban slum
outside of Lima whose inhabitants
compared it to the surface of the Moon
my travels with farmer he showed me more
reasons for despair than I'd ever seen
before or indeed imagined and yet it was
the most exhilarating experience of my
life to witness what one small group of
people were accomplishing in their quest
to cure some of the world's most
dreadful problems personally I feel very
lucky to have stumbled across Paul
Farmer it's made my life more
interesting and I think more meaningful
I also feel lucky professionally that
chance meeting in Haiti led me to a
story that I believe rather mystically I
had always wanted to write and it also
led me to another story a story that is
partly about effective altruism a story
like Paul farmers but also very
different an intriguing and mysterious
story a horrifying and hopeful story a
story that offered me a chance to write
that thing of things
a page-turner with a heart and mind I
hope I pulled it off about six years ago
my wife and I went to visit Paul farmer
in his apartment at Harvard where he was
laid up after a knee operation a young
African a protege of farmers named Dale
gracias happened to be there and as it
turned out I spent most of the time
talking with Paul while my wife talked
with Dale on the ride home she told me
the rough outlines of the story that
Dale had told her and the memory of a
secondhand account of Dale's memories
stuck with me for several years until
finally I decided that I should hear
this story for myself he was born and
raised in their small and impoverished
East Africa East Central African nation
of Burundi he's the son of Tutsi cow
murders and farmers he managed to excel
in school and was beginning his fourth
year of medical training
whence ethnic civil war erupted it was a
war between Hutus and Tutsis a division
too complex and strange to explain in
the time I have today the war lasted for
about 12 years
it claimed several hundred thousand
lives and early on it also helped to
ignite the notorious genocide in Rwanda
which began of course in April 1994
Burundi civil war began six months
earlier with the assassination of its
first elected president Deus Flight
started the following day when a group
of militia attacked the hospital where
he was working he made a six months long
escape on foot first from Burundi across
the border to Rwanda then from the
genocide of Tutsis in Rwanda back to
Burundi and then through a series of
complex maneuverings to New York City
where he landed with 200 dollars in his
pocket no contacts perfect command of
French and none at all of English and an
eroding dream of returning to medicine
you
so traumatized at that point that he
sometimes confused past and present
he lived first in abandoned tenements in
Harlem and then in Central Park which he
found more salubrious working as a
grocery delivery boy for $15 a day he
met an ex contemplative nun a truly
remarkable woman
I don't think I've ever enjoyed writing
about anyone more anyway thanks to her
efforts he was taken in by a childless
American couple and not very long
afterward and probably enough he
enrolled as an undergraduate at Columbia
University during his time of
homelessness des was afflicted with what
he called some kind of unrealistic pride
before heading for bed in Central Park
he would look all around to make sure no
strangers were watching because he
figured that anyone who saw him entering
the park at night would guess that he
was homeless when he told me about doing
this I thought of my daughter once as a
young teenager visiting New York she
began to cross a busy street against the
light my wife yelled at her and in cold
fury my daughter said thanks a lot mom
for ruining my reputation in New York
City
day-o rescued himself from hopelessness
and maybe even from insanity partly
through libraries and bookstores where
he would go every evening after work and
look up English words and page longingly
through books in English pretending to
himself that he was actually reading
them it was a quick study at Columbia he
majored both in biochemistry and clearly
not for practical reasons in philosophy
the book I've written about him
strengthen what remains is divided in
two parts in the first I recount des
owes memories and in the second I depict
him in the throes of those memories I
like to think that on one level the
first part of my book is simply an
exciting story a tale of survival of
despair and determination evil and
kindness
to me day-o seems like a more Universal
figure than Paul Farmer deo is at the
outset at least a more ordinary person a
person who through no act of his own has
put in an extraordinary utterly perilous
situation I can't imagine doing what
either he or Paul Farmer has done but I
think most of us would be much more apt
to measure ourselves against deo to ask
what would have happened to me in his
place I hope I've reproduced some of the
feeling that came over me when I first
heard Dale's account of his life that I
would not have survived I also hope that
my book humanizes what to most
Westerners anyway is a mysterious
little-known part of the world we hear
about mass slaughter and distant
countries and we imagine that murder and
mayhem define those locales
day-o story opens up one of those places
into a comprehensible landscape and also
opens up a part of New York that is
designed to be invisible the service
entrances of the Upper East Side the
camping sites that homeless people make
in Central Park the second part of my
book recounts my journeys with Deyo back
to the Stations of his life in New York
and in rwanda and burundi it strikes me
as mildly ironic that I decided to leave
my New England neighborhood just when
I'd begun to feel too old too fussy too
addicted to my comforts for Paul farmers
and days kind of travel by the time I
went to Africa with Deyo I had very
little appetite left for all-night plane
rides and none at all for riding around
and what I imagined were dangerous
places on one occasion in Burundi I
found myself so spooked that I asked
Dayo not to take me to a certain village
actually I demand that that he not take
me there which is a pretty curious act
for a writer if you think about it
before we set out for Burundi Dayo
assured me that we would be we would be
very safe there
but then he also said that he'd rather I
didn't take notes openly that I should
not publicly utter the name
Hutu or Tutsi and that I should never
never speak the word genocide in fact I
think we were safe physically reticence
about the past I learned is the rule in
Burundi the native language contains an
interesting perhaps uniquely economical
word whose simbra it's a transitive verb
the gusenberg
others is to remind them of something
unpleasant particularly by Nate by
uttering the names of the dead and to
Goose Umbra someone is worse than
impolite for me the word came to express
an essential part of my experiences with
Dale deep down I think strengthen what
remains is about coming to terms with
memory how can a person deal with
memories like de oz tormenting memories
memories with a distinctly uncover
nerble quality this is why my book is
structured as it is the reason for its
doubleness the story I tell isn't only
about memories I heard from Dale but
also about seeing him overtaken by
memories acutely overtaken in several
places including locales he hadn't seen
since his escape 13 years ago the
village where he was born and raised at
the hospital where he was nearly killed
at the outset of the civil war but they
didn't make that trip just to show me
around my tour of his past was
incidental to what he was up to in the
present and the future his story has add
a new mod that even now amazes me when I
first began following him around Dale
had permanent residency and was soon to
become an American citizen he didn't
have to go back to Burundi in his place
I don't think I would have gone back
especially given the fact that the first
time he went home to see his family he
was nearly killed Dale could have lived
a decent of an exemplary life in the
United States as many refugees have no
one could have blamed him if he'd stayed
away from Burundi where even now
hospitalized patients who can't pay
their bills are detained imprisoned
essentially without food or care but Deo
has returned continually and keeps on
returning to the country that almost
killed him and amid the post-war
wreckage with the help of friends and
family he has created an organization
called village health works which among
other things has built a clinic and a
public health system free to those who
can't pay in a rural village part of a
beginning dale hopes of a renewed
Burundi building and staffing and
supplying a clinic in a desperately poor
country isn't easy this clinic was a
pile of rocks when I visited the site
with Deyo in the summer of 2006 by the
fall of 2008 though it was a growing
public health system that for starters
was providing food to the hungriest
people in the area and clean water to
all of them and it was also a medical
center with several new buildings a
professional staff and a fully stocked
pharmacy in its first year of operation
it treated 21,000 different patients
most of them for free there was and
still is nothing like this clinic in
Burundi nothing
elsewhere in Burundi anyway people come
there for help from all over the country
and they've been coming there in
staggering numbers lately because all
the doctors and all the other public
facilities in Burundi have been on
strike some patients have come on week
long treks from other countries from the
Congo and Tanzania and there have also
been a few a few visitors who have come
not for medical help but only to look at
the clinic when Deo asked one of these
travelers why he was there the man
replied to see America a sentiment for
us to live up to perhaps they was very
young when he went through his long
nightmare sheer courage and pluck saved
him from death and despair in Burundi in
New York so of course that the ex-nun
and the
family that adopted him and new york's
libraries and bookstores in columbia
university but when it's come to dealing
with the burden of his memories the
public health system and clinic that he
founded are their nearest thing to a
solution in the end it's neither
forgetting the past nor dwelling on the
past that has worked for him for him the
answer has been remembering and acting
and once asked him why he had studied
philosophy at columbia he told me i
wanted to understand what had happened
to me in the end of course he received
what all students of philosophy received
not answers just more questions but as i
was trying to explain his effort to
build a clinic i found myself writing
deo had discovered a way to quiet the
questions he'd been asking at columbia
that is he saw there might be an answer
for what troubled him most about the
world an answer that lay in his hands
indeed in his memory you had to do
something thank you
physically everybody at that that that
also sounds a lot better than my book
yeah a lot a lot better
the gosh hey hey
the next panelist is is is the lovely
Jeannette Walls who who wrote a book
called the glass castle which is like
half a gazillion copies no in print yeah
and and as I said I've started reading
this book and I can't tell it's terrific
I mean really no I don't know what
you're gonna say about it but this
starts with a flash flood and the kids
and you're like ah and then it just
takes you on this rollercoaster ride you
put that on the cover if you want
alright a roller coaster yeah that'll
sell it for you it's a roller coaster
ride I'm sorry everybody I'm gonna
literate boob Jeannette Walls
if I were to say it that I'm happy to be
here that would be an understatement
I am filled with joy and Glee utter
utter ecstasy at this moment and at ease
a bit of a feeling like I've overreached
myself what Craigs it was lovely about
the panel all being smarter than ever be
out here but it's it's not true um I am
just a woman with a story but the
telling of that story has changed my
life
I I think I've learned a lot about the
world and perhaps even some things about
myself and it's largely because of
readers and y'all in here in this room
are my gateway to readers so I'm deeply
honored and joyous to be standing here
and I'd like to share with you some of
the things that I've learned I actually
owe readers for the topic of my next
book my forthcoming book half broke
horses um but you know as I sat down to
write my last book the glass castle I
thought why am I doing this why am i
exposing myself to what I was certain
was gonna be humiliation and shame and
degradation I thought I'd have
everything I wanted in this world you
know I had a great job I was I was on
television I I had a flush toilet what
more could anybody want in life you know
and I thought if somebody can read my
story and can understand what it's like
to be poor then whatever shame and
embarrassment I'm about to go through
will be worth it and then I developed an
even fonder hope for my book and that
was that somebody who grew up like me
would read it and and might get a little
glimmer of hope for my story not long
after the publication of the Glass
Castle the teacher came up to me and she
said that she had a student in her class
she teaches in a tough area in northern
Alabama real rough Scrabble area she
said a young man who doesn't like books
and doesn't like reading came up to her
I was carrying the book around and said
he enjoyed it she said I thought you
don't enjoy books he said I don't she
said I thought you don't like reading is
that I don't like reading and she said
but you like this book why is that and
he thinks for a second and he said this
here is a fine white trash story
and then the teacher paused for a second
and she said a little bit nervously she
said I think he meant that as a
compliment
but I took it as perhaps the greatest
compliment the book could have possibly
received because if a young man who
thinks of himself as trash who thinks
that literature and writing and books
have nothing to do with him
if he hears my story and says hey you
know something she's a little bit like
me
that I believe is is why we tell stories
you know I don't tell that story to brag
about my book but to brag about the
power of storytelling and that's what
everybody in this room is in the
business of we're all in the business of
storytelling and I think that sometimes
we memoirs and biographers we get a
little bit of a bum rap is exhibitionist
and you know creating a freak show and
so trainwreck people stare at it and I
especially after having spoken to
readers for the last couple of years I
believe that that is not at all why we
tell these stories it's because readers
are looking for an emotional connection
they're looking to find out a little bit
about about people who might from a
distance look very different they they
might be from from Africa or might be
from faraway Scotland and but you know
once you get inside somebody's life and
we we break down these external barriers
and get in people's lives understand
we're all incredibly alike and having
spoken to readers around the country you
know they have this great passion about
understanding themselves not just other
people's lives but why they are who they
are in and I believe that that is why we
read biographies but um as I said is
that the last couple of years I gave up
my day job I used to write about
celebrities but I've been spending the
last couple of years going around and
talking about my book and readers have
really stunned me with their insights
about about my life believe it or not
there's been a couple of times one time
I was in an event and somebody she
raised her hand and she said why did
your mother make this particular
decision out of a I said you know I
don't know and I tried to ask my mother
I can't get a straight answer from her
so I don't know somebody else in the
audience raises her hand she said I know
I said you do she said yeah my book club
discussed it so
so I love book clubs I love readers you
know we said and then we had these
intimate conversations about but anyway
as I was going around talking to people
the questions I got more than any other
were about my mother people they wanted
to know for those of you who aren't
familiar with my story um my mother was
a college-educated woman my mother and
father they were living on the streets
for a while while I was living in New
York City and people just wanted to know
some people got my mom some people said
I understand your mother but more people
would say I understand your father he
was an alcoholic I understand the
decisions he made I do not understand
why your mother made some of the
decisions that she made and the
questions were never asked out of malice
or at work no zena's it just people have
this this desire to to get inside
somebody's head and figure things out
it's all about psychology so they you
know why would your mother who has a
college education choose to live a life
where she had no electricity or running
water and sometimes I'd explained to
them well my mother grew up on 180,000
acre ranch and she didn't have running
water and she didn't have electricity
and she not only survived but it was it
was the ideal period of her life it was
the the period of her life that she most
loved and then invariably their lot
their faces light up they'll say oh oh I
get it and they would often have a
really interesting conversation after
that about expectations of life and
about motherhood and childhood what
people want and the difference between
wanting things and meeting things and
usually these conversations would end
with your next book should be about your
mother again i mold out a little bit but
I've been kicking around for a topic for
a new book and I sort of resisted the
idea of writing about mom I figured I
already said if you know I squeeze that
sponge once why do I go back to but but
readers tend to be very smart so I
proposed the idea to mom I said what
would you think about writing this book
about about you she loved the idea you
know mom mom bless her heart she lives
with me now not with me cuz I'm not a
saint but she lives out back in um
we uh it's you know it's a mobile home
but we put on airs and call it the vinyl
cottage but you know it has running
water has electricity mom I've never
known her to be so happy you know she's
she at first she resisted the idea of
she said I never the most exciting city
in the world why would I go down a
little Virginia that's the sticks and I
said you know mom you live on this
street she said I'm not some sort of
mooch I'm not gonna take advantage of my
my daughter my son-in-law I said mom we
thinking of getting horses and could
really use the help and she said I'll be
right there and you know that that's
also taught me a lot about life and in
helping people if we can help them help
themselves not only will they be more
likely to take us up on it but they
actually might surprise us and rise to
the occasion
but anyway mom has been fabulous about
about telling her story for a solid year
I went down to the vinyl cottage for an
hour a day and she would tell me about
her life her her childhood in the 1930s
and 40s in in Arizona on this hundred
and eighty thousand acre ranch but as
she was telling me she kept saying you
know this story should not be about me
it should be about my mother my mother
led the truly interesting life and at
first I resisted because I see myself as
a nonfiction writer I have no
imagination I'm not good at making
things up I tried to fictionalize the
glass castle I could even think of fake
names for us I used all our middle names
so um I really resisted but as I sat
down to try to write a half broke horses
I am I was trying to write it in mom's
voice I was trying to suit it was gonna
be a biography of my mother and I found
it very difficult to capture her voice
to get inside her head it was a sort of
scary place to be so um I am I stride
riding every other chapter from you've
one chapter from Mom's point of view and
then one from my grandmother's point of
view and is whenever I wrote in my
grandmother's voice it really clicked I
just I understand my grandmother I
I knew her only for the early part of my
life she died when I was 8 but I
remember her very vividly she was a wild
character and she carried around a gun
and she'd pull it out on the drop of a
hat and shoot at things pull out a fake
teeth or the drop of a hat she you know
she was just a real character leathery
woman and
I understand my grandmother so I tried
riding in her voice and it just it
seemed to sort of happen and I wrote it
in first-person um my grandmother she
was born in a dugout I don't mean on a
baseball field she was born on the banks
of a river in 1901 and her grand her
father raised horses he raised carriage
horses but because he was crippled my
grandmother had to do all the physical
work she was the one who actually
climbed on the backs of the horses and
she became a schoolteacher at age 15 she
didn't yet have a high school diploma
she was really tough for her to get a
high school education but she was just a
tough broad she was a tough broad and
she did what it took to get by and that
was her story and in so many ways she's
an extraordinary woman you know she just
she's a true American character and and
lived in a time and in a way that is
very unfamiliar to a lot of us today but
in another way I think that she's the
story of a lot of us you know I think
that a lot of people will recognize
themselves in this story especially
after having gone into so many parts of
the country talking to people to readers
you know a lot of people out there
really face are facing tough times and
and and are looking for somebody to
relate to and I'm somebody who they can
connect with and again I think that
that's that's why we we write these
memoirs is to try to find somebody like
this but but um as I was writing as I
was writing half broke horses I thought
of it as as initially as nonfiction
because it was my grandmother's story
but because I wrote it in first-person
and because there's some things that I
sort of used what I would call the
storytellers license I stapled together
things that I wasn't completely sure
I've used a little putty here and there
I'd originally intended to change it all
back into the third person she did this
instead of I did this and I just I left
it in the first person and we're and
we're calling it a true life novel we're
calling it fiction even though it is as
closely based on my grandmother's like
as I possibly can make it I don't know
how much of it is true my mother um my
mother who does not know my phone number
who cannot remember her own social
security number has in a
Daanish in recall for details of her
childhood and stories from her mother
who was an incredible storyteller my
grandmother is she was a schoolteacher
and she just loved to tell stories
everything was a lesson so these stories
were told over and over again to her and
they're passed down stories basically
it's a family history and I was you know
when I was interviewing mom she kept on
telling me she had all these details
about Arizona history and the human
language and how it split among the
Indian tribes and 800 AD and I was how
can mom I how can she know all this
stuff and so I said mom how can you know
all this stuff and you can't remember my
soul your own social security number she
said my social security number is not
that interesting so so so I just had a
trusted her recall for these things but
like I said I'm still calling the book
fiction and but it is it is the story of
of my grandmother it's a family story as
passed down yesterday somebody was
asking me what is what is my ambition
what is my hope for half broke horses
what is the the number that I would like
for it to sell and and it's an
interesting question I'd I'd never had
any ambition for for the glass castle I
never expected it to take off the way
there so so it has just been such an
unexpected blessing but the way that has
been received somebody asked me if it's
a dream come true it has so far exceeded
anything I would have ever dared dream
and it's it's thanks to readers for
being so open-minded and so smart about
it and finding that emotional connection
and I guess at that that is my my dream
for half broke horses you know that in
the same way that that young white-trash
voice would have recognized himself in
in the glass castle my dream for half
broke horses is that folks out in
America you know whatever their
background whatever their circumstances
that they will read it and recognize
that they'll find out something about a
world that is different from theirs but
then also one that is sort of similar to
their own they will recognize their own
struggles in the struggle of Lily Casey
Smith
and and I guess my my real dream for
half broke horses is that one day you
know some woman will come up to me some
woman who looks like she has herself a
tough scrabble life somebody who looks
like she's struggling to make ends meet
and she'll say to me that there is one
fine tough broad story thank you very
much JC
that was everybody hey I love the idea
that of the telling these stories is
somehow a communication I I began to see
I began to see a thread when Tracy was
speaking and and then after you genera
but this idea that I had that I have
noticed that um in a very small way I I
mean I live in Los Angeles which is an
awful place
and I mean it really is even people who
live in a label see this is a dirt box
this is awful but I lived there and when
there's a lot of pushing and shoving and
arguments and and and stuff on the
freeway and and when I when I can
humanize the person that's cutting me
off in traffic I don't succumb to rage
and and when I and when I I'm kind of
like a serial killer I think I think
once I can make people human I can't
destroy them you know I can't no oh now
they have personalities I can't it rubs
the lotion on its skin no because now
it's like I've given it a name and I
think that the I think that is there is
something and that I don't like the idea
of myself being a serial killer but I do
I do think that as you humanize a day or
and as you humanize your grandmother and
as we get to ban who who chronicles a
generation that I don't really
understand you know the the and and you
you all have to deal with this now as
well and people it has been said to me
this week
you have to tweet more before the book I
don't know what tweeting is I'm not part
of this this is no I don't have a
skateboard
nevermind tweet and I go I don't tweet a
load before the booze I'll be tweeting
every day I won't read a damn word of it
but I'll be but I it'll be old Tweety
tree trader getting out of my car going
over here oh yeah I mean this is to me
rubbish but
that's because it's not for me it's not
for me and and like each generation that
comes before that I think that uh
yesterday or I might hip hurts and
that's not true there are remarkable
brilliant fascinating odd young minds
coming up all the time and they and they
work in a world which I beginning to
find myself a bit of a quarter I don't
understand it you know and so I complain
and say things were better during
punk-rock when everybody everybody hated
each other you knew where you stood kids
today with their ideas and they're
inventing things God you know
however a Ben can humanize these people
for me and I and I cannot hate them and
and and so please welcome Ben Mezrich
everyone
hello everybody good morning uh I gotta
try and humanize my generation now but
um I want to start off by just thanking
everyone in thanking uh the booksellers
and the beas for having me like a lot of
you I've been a book geek since I was
little
my dad had a rule when we were little
that we had to read two books a week
before we were allowed to watch TV and I
was obsessed with television so that
became an obsession with books because I
had to get through two books a week and
luckily he counted every type of book
from science fiction to anything so I
became a speed reader at about the age
of 10 and I knew I wanted to be a writer
from about then at about 12 I wrote my
first book which I sent out to
publishers hopefully nobody in this room
and and I got rejected which which still
led me to keep writing and when I
graduated from college I locked myself
in a room and I wrote and I wrote and I
wrote and I wrote nine novels in a year
and they were deep dark stories that
took place in bars in New York City
because I was reading a lot of Bret
Easton Ellis and Jay McInerney and I
thought that's what writers write and
consequently I got 190 rejection slips
in one year and I used to tape them to
my walls and I'd sit in a room covered
with rejection but but I was used to
rejection I'm a pretty geeky guy so
College was all about rejection for me
and I went from there and I decided I'm
gonna keep doing this I'm gonna keep
doing this and I met an editor actually
from Random House who said you should
read some John Grisham and then come
back in a year and so I went and I read
John Grisham and I read Michael Crichton
and I said I could do this I could write
a thriller and my dad's a doctor so I
thought okay I'll write a medical
thriller so I wrote a medical thriller
and it's sold and I managed to get a
second medical thriller and and and
these were you know pop pop thrillers my
second book was called Reaper I don't
think anybody here remembers and don't
worry about that and it was about a
computer virus that makes the jump to
the biological world and people start
getting sick from their TV sets and that
was trashy enough to end up as a TV
movie starring Antonio sabato jr. the
underwear model great guy I actually was
on set and he did crunches in between
his takes and so he was in very good
shape and he played a surgeon in the
movie
and I remember there's a scene where
he's leaning over this patient's chest
and he goes we've got a subdural
hematoma and I'm watching you with my
dad who was a doctor and he says you
know that's in the head right and I was
like yeah I wasn't really I didn't have
any power on set which you know and I
was a thriller writer and that was you
know that was the voice that I had found
at the time and and that's where I was
gonna go I I had no you know knowledge
of nonfiction I didn't know anything
about nonfiction at the time but I used
to hang out in this bar in Boston and
the borrow is called crossroads if any
of you happen to go to Boston and oh
yeah there you go like trashy bars I
like that it's a it's an MIT dive bar
and there were these geeky and mighty
kids who used to hang out there and they
were your regular math science kids
except for strangely enough they had
tons of money and it was always in
hundred-dollar bills and in Boston you
never see a hundred dollar bill you know
in New York you see hundred dollar bills
you know in in Vegas you see they come
out of the ATM machines right but in
Boston the last time I saw a hundred
dollar bill I don't can't even remember
so I went over to this kid and I said
why do you have so much money and he
invites me to his house so I go over
this kid's house and he points to his
laundry and stacked above his laundry
it's two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and hundreds in banded stacks
and I'm like okay this guy's a drug
dealer but you know I didn't look like a
drug dealer and he said no no I'm not a
drug dealer
come to Vegas and the next day I flew to
Vegas because I was in that part of my
life and I landed in Vegas and six of
his friends flew with us and they all
get out and we all they pretended they
didn't know each other and we go to this
suite it was like a suite overlooking
the hall the whole strip and the kids
start to pull money out from under their
clothes and they had a million dollars
in cash that they had flown from Boston
to Vegas with and they pile it up on the
table and they say we're the mit
blackjack team and I was blown away and
I realized you know I'm gonna become a
nonfiction writer because this is the
craziest thing I've ever seen and I
joined the team and I played with them
for about six months and and you know it
was a crazy experience being like the
donkey boy if any of you saw the movie
21 I was the guy who strapped a quarter
million dollars to my body and did all
that stuff and it was intense and then
it got more intense because Kevin Spacey
called me about
week before the book came out and
somehow he had gotten a copy of it and
said I want to make a movie and so then
you know it was made into a movie which
was really cool and so you know I was a
nonfiction writer and I had stumbled
into it and accidental billionaires is
my new book that's coming out in July
and this book I really stumbled into as
well like a lot of you I love Facebook
I'm obsessed with Facebook actually my
wife is over there is really obsessed
with Facebook and she carries the camera
around and embarrassing you and takes
photos you know everywhere we go it ends
up on Facebook that night so you might
all end up on Facebook tonight but
basically I love Facebook I had been
using it by knew nothing about it I knew
it had started at Harvard where I had
gone to school but you know I didn't
know anything about it
I was sitting at home and at 2:00 in the
morning I get this email to my website
and this kid goes you know I'm a Harvard
senior and I've got a crazy story for
you and you know all writers have heard
that a million times I've got a crazy
story for you and I was like well I'm
intrigued what's your story and he said
well my best friend you know co-founded
Facebook it was like your best friend's
Mark Zuckerberg but his best friend
wasn't Mark Zuckerberg and I thought
that's interesting I don't anything
about he said we'll come meet me for a
drink and so I go off and I meet him for
a drink in a bar and he shows up with
this geeky gawky kid this kid with long
stringy arms really nice brilliant kid
and the kid walks in and starts to tell
me this insane story about he and his
best friend coming up with the idea for
Facebook and I was really intrigued
because I was a geeky gawky kid at
Harvard and I knew what Harvard was like
for geeky gawky kids and I thought this
might be the next story and I started to
get deeper and deeper into it and it is
a wild wild story these kids were best
friends and they met one was a sophomore
and one was a junior and they met in an
underground Jewish fraternity at Harvard
there are underground fraternities at
Harvard and they were the kind of kids
who really weren't getting a lot of
girls and and you know they wanted to be
cooler than they were they were
brilliant one of them whose name was
Eduardo was obsessed with meteorology
whether with his thing and he had
actually come up with these these
mathematical equations that he could
predict storms and so during a summer he
had made a few hundred thousand dollars
trading oil stocks we
his brother and so that was kind of his
claim to fame at college the other kid
whose name was Mark Zuckerberg who a lot
of people know the name mark was a
hacker an incredible computer scientist
he had rumored the rumor was that in
high school he had been on an FBI
hacking list he was that good he had
actually invented an mp3 player a piece
of software when he was a 17 years old
that Microsoft came and offered him a
million dollars for and he just turned
it down and then put it online for free
because he didn't really care about
money he was he was you know that kind
of a kid and the two of them were best
friends and they wanted you know more
people to know who they were they wanted
to meet girls
Eduardo thought the way to make it you
know at Harvard was to become a member
of the finals clubs some of you might
know what they are they're kind of
Harvard's answers to the skullenbones
they're semi secret societies they're
10% of the student body does them and
they're these old buildings that go back
hundreds of years and they're male only
and you join these these finals clubs
threw a punch period where you go
through these different events and you
sort of get judged all the way through
and then 10% of the student body gets in
and that's where the social center of
Harvard is these finals clubs so Eduardo
thought you know if I can become a
member of the finals club I could become
cool and so he went in that and he ended
up getting punched for one of them it's
called the Phoenix which is this grand
old building where I spent a lot of time
researching this book and he was slowly
on his way to doing that
now mark wasn't gonna get into the
Phoenix and he actually went in a
different route late at night at about
2:00 in the morning he was having a few
drinks and he decided he was gonna pull
a college prank and he hacked into all
of the university's computers and he
took pictures all the pictures of every
single girl on campus and he made a sort
of hot-or-not website and I don't
remember that website but it was a site
where you could get to pictures of girls
would come up and you could vote on
which one was hotter and this actually
he didn't really mean to send it out but
he ended up sending it to a couple
friends and it spread and while he was
at 20,000 logs went on to that site
20,000 people voted and by the time he
came back it had frozen all
the campus computers and he realized
that he was in a lot of trouble and he
unplugged it very quickly and he nearly
got kicked out of school what was
amazing about mark was he was he didn't
really know why he was in trouble he
didn't think that he had done anything
really wrong and in his mind he had
pointed out a problem with the computer
systems at Harvard and he also didn't
really understand why all the women's
groups on campus were very upset at him
he had gotten letters from it had been
emailed the link to his website had been
emailed to all of the women's groups on
campus and they had freaked out about it
but he had gotten in big trouble and he
had ended up in the school paper and
when he had ended up in the school paper
he caught the attention of two other
characters that are in this book and
they're the Winklevoss twins and these
guys come right out of a Hollywood movie
6 foot 5 Olympic rowing identical twins
they're mirror image of each other ones
left being ones righty and they look
like Ben Affleck I mean they are you
walk into the room with these guys and
you're like you're this is crazy these
guys are like robots because they rode
together they rode in Beijing in a
single boat and they were kind of the
cool kids on campus they're you know
we're Olympic athletes they were in the
club called the priscilly on which is
the ultimate finals Club at Harvard the
priscilly anit so secretive that women
are only allowed in twice on the day you
marry them and on your 20th anniversary
and and no other time as a woman ever
allowed in that building which is pretty
crazy and these kids were members of
this ultra secret Club they were jocks
they were the cool kids on campus and
they also had an idea for a website they
were trying to make a dating website
which at the time they had called the
Harvard connection which ended up being
called connect you and they needed a
geek because they didn't know how to
computer program that well and so they
basically saw a Mark Zuckerberg in the
newspaper and said we're gonna hire this
kid as a geek now I want to preface it
by saying when you meet these kids they
are the the nicest guys in the world and
they're very self-aware I remember
walking into the room with them and they
said I know you're looking at us and
thinking were the bad guys because if
this were an 80s movie we would be
dressed as skeletons chasing the Karate
Kid around the party because we're the
big you know blond good-looking guys but
in their mind they're not the bad guys
they hired Mark Zuckerberg to code their
website anyways about
week later Mark Zuckerberg and Eduardo
were sitting having lunch and they were
thinking about the whole incident with
the college prank that went bad and how
they hadn't gotten kicked out of school
very luckily and they thought to
themselves well what if girls could put
their own pictures up and so you weren't
stealing their pictures the girls could
put their own pictures up and then I
could go and look at the girls and and
make connections with them and they
basically had the idea of Facebook right
there they thought you know what if we
let people have their own control and
put their own photos up and so they said
okay we're gonna do this so mark
basically locked himself in a room and
and for about a week programmed and
programmed and programmed and launched
Facebook Eduardo put in a thousand
dollars which is what they needed to
rent the servers and Facebook was
launched and very quickly it pretty much
exploded when Facebook first started you
had to have a Harvard edu you had to
have a Harvard computer address to log
on because the idea was they were gonna
make their own finals Club it would be
just as exclusive as the Porcellian or
the Phoenix but it would be online so
you had to be a Harvard student within
about two weeks
everyone at Harvard was logged on 5,000
people were logged on I've got a month
later they decided to start moving it
around from other to other Ivy League
schools and very shortly there were
twenty thousand members and it was
moving very very quickly and it got to
Stanford and Stanford you know was a
hotbed of Silicon Valley a lot of young
people were there and this is where a
kid named Sean Parker comes into the
story Sean Parker is the craziest person
I've ever met he's brilliant a genius
when he was 17 he was in high school and
he co-founded Napster with his buddy
Shawn Fanning when he was about twenty
twenty-one he founded Plaxo he ended up
getting kicked out of Plaxo and he was
looking for the next billion-dollar idea
and he was basically lying in a dorm
like room when he saw a laptop computer
that had the facebook screen on it and
he thought this might be my next
billion-dollar idea so he flew out to
Cambridge he ended up meeting up with
Mark Zuckerberg and Eduardo and he said
I'm gonna try and take this to the next
level and the rest is kind of history it
went from there and it went from 20,000
members to a hundred thousand members to
five hundred thousand members all the
way to a million members and things
start to fray between the two best
friends Eduardo and Mark I mean there
were two kids in a
when they came up with the idea mark
went off to California to Silicon Valley
and started to really work on the idea
Eduardo went to New York to sell ads for
the idea and there was sort of a
falling-out
by the time Facebook reached a million
members the two kids became enemies and
were no longer friends
Eduardo kind of vanished from Facebook's
history and only about a month ago was
he reinstated as co-founder which may
have something to do with this book
coming out and may not but it was a
really intense process getting inside of
it I mean I know everyone in the world
uses Facebook and everyone loves it but
not everyone knows that it was really
founded by the two most socially awkward
geeky kids at Harvard who really
couldn't meet girls and couldn't be
social and it's ironic that they created
the next revolution in in in society and
it's the biggest social network in the
world the biggest picture site in the
world the biggest everything in the
world and it's just gonna keep getting
bigger and we are working on a movie
it's actually going very quickly Aaron
Sorkin did the screenplay and a
brilliant man it was an odd experience
normally you write the book and you send
it out and then someone adapts it he was
adapting it while I wrote it we would
sit in a hotel room in Boston and and
basically trade information back and
forth which is a wild experience Kevin
Spacey is co-producing it with Scott
Rudin and and it's with Sony Pictures
and then that's gonna move along very
nicely so it's gonna be fun hopefully
it'll be out soon and everyone with the
book comes out in July it's called
accidental billionaires and I just want
to thank you all very much for having me
thank you
all right that pretty much concludes our
panel this morning I i I realized though
just there that I am doomed to financial
failure because of my ability to
converse with women who I'd much rather
have in the room with me that's right
I'm lecherous old school I I thank you
for coming I realized that I haven't
said the name of my one book which will
cause a great deal of consternation down
there so it's called American on purpose
and I'm proud of it
I am I'm honored to have spent the
morning with these delightful talented
people and and and thank you and thank
you for including me in this wonderful
event
have fun and I'll see you don't dare
talk to anyone before they're at the
booth don't talk to people before the
booth it's like the new Fight Club thing
don't talk to people until they're at
the booth thank you and good morning
everyone